what is safety by Design and why should
we fear it surely if it's limited to
combating terrorism and child porn it's
a good thing if my grandmother had
Wheels she would be a wagon surely if
that if the premise went through then we
would all agree with that of course but
unfortunately the premise is not true
and Julie Grant and the world economic
Forum are trying to hide that they're
trying to say that this new method of
policing speech online is simply to
combat child pornography and personal
attacks and threats and the like that's
not the case and you can see it actually
from the world economic forum's own
website on the matter when they list all
of the evils that the safety by Design
will combat the first thing they list is
Health misinformation child pornography
actually comes later on down the line